voilà des Chinois derrière nos bureaux
de tabac c'est une tendance forte comme
à Paris ailleurs en province les Chinois
s'installent au comptoir des bureaux de
tabac en Charente volontiers suivis par
les banques parce qu'ils n'ont pas peur
de faire des heures alors il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont dit que c'était
abusé c'est une est-ce que vous trouvez
que c'est abusé ou pas du tout Gilles
Verdez bien sûr oui mais Guillaume
depuis quand chinois c'est une insulte
c'est une femme sur la photo elle est
pas d'origine visiblement suédoise ou
congolaise c'est une jeune femme
s'expliquée dans l'article c'est pas
gratuit si jeune femme française
d'origine chinoise il y a une réalité
aujourd'hui dans les grandes villes et
en France que les tabacs sont rachetés
par la communauté chinoise qui sont
parfois chinois qui sont parfois
franco-chinois parfois des Français
d'origine chinoise pourquoi à chaque
fois des comprenons un mot c'est vu
comme du racisme et un moment il faut
être volontiers
on peut dire les Français les Marocains
les Chinois les les Japonais il faut
être fier de ses origines pourquoi c'est
vu combien sur en plus cet article vente
les Chinois parce qu'ils disent que
culturellement ils ont une meilleure
approche du travail que nous et qu'ils
arrivent à mieux travailler c'est pour
ça merci
c'est plutôt positif parce qu'ils disent
qu'ils font plus d'heures que les autres
c'est plutôt positif on le sait la
communiquer chinoise ça fait beaucoup
d'heures ces gens qui qui qui pèsent pas
le travail et heureusement que qui sont
derrière les non c'est pas bien
donc voilà il y a plein
de trouver sa stigmatisant ou
discriminant là ça l'est pas je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec Guillaume mais
de dire en gros les Chinois c'est des
bosseurs et les dossiers des glandeurs
là ça veut dire que oui
mais même si c'est des clichés c'est pas
grave on les restaurants les corps sont
des cercles de jeu moi
il n'y a aucun racisme là
justement là il faut le condamner pour
dire que là ça en est pas du tout quoi
sauf que là Géraldine le titre est quand
même problématique pardonne-moi des
Chinois des Chinois derrière nos bureaux
de tabac sous-entendu des Chinois
prendre l'eau de tabac à nous Français
les Chinois nous envahissent voilà c'est
ça qui est terrible moi j'adore Charente
Libre mais là c'est pas ça c'est du
racisme ordinaire c'est un très bon
journal mais là c'est du racisme
ordinaire c'est stigma disait une
communauté il aurait fallu titrer sur la
jeune femme cette jeune femme a racheté
et là parfait avec l'exemple reportage
mais là c'est une dénonciation derrière
ok
moi je suis d'accord c'est derrière nos
bureaux de tabac c'est c'est l'ont
acheté ils l'ont acheté avec leur argent
c'est pas nos bureaux de tabac si
personne veut reprendre les bureaux de
tabac parce qu'il faut se lever à 6h du
matin il faut rester jusqu'à 21h c'est
pas c'est pas de la faute et moi je
quand tu dis des Chinois quand vous
dites des Chinois on peut dire aussi des
asiatiques parce que qui vous dit que
c'est que tout le temps des Chinois le
problème il est là il est là le problème
c'est que quand on dit à quelqu'un dans
la rue un chinois des fois c'est un
japonais c'est incroyable c'est pas
forcément un chinois ça peut être aussi
un asiatique
mais derrière nos bureaux de tabac c'est
pas nos bureaux de tabac si on arrive
pas nous on racheter des tabacs c'est
qu'il y a un souci c'est qu'il y a un
problème le décalage l'hypocrisie en
fait entre comme on parle dans la vraie
vie comme tout à l'heure mais sur les
plateaux télé Guillaume et le tribunal
médiatique de Twitter on n'a pas le
droit de dire chinois mais les gars le
client avec la prof le quartier chinois
les quartiers chinators c'est quoi c'est
des Finlandais qui sont là-bas non c'est
des Chinois
par une autre par une autre moi c'est
vrai par contre une communauté
tu vois bien sûr
réponds-moi
asiatiques c'est pas pareil là il y a
une réalité ce sont des Chinois qui
reprennent l'économie
des Arabes c'est stigmatisant là c'est
une réalité ce sont des
Suédois reprennent des boucheries ben si
c'était vrai
attendez je sais de changer des
Irlandais reprennent nos magasins c'est
le chou rouge
merci non vous avez raison
c'est la formulation qui est un peu
choquante mais maintenant des chinois
c'est pas une insulte il faut quand même
le rappeler on parle comme ça tous
reprennent nos cabines à UV ça marche
pour moi c'est des vérités après je
pense que les gens qui lisent ce genre
de magasin ils ont le droit de se faire
leur opinion eux-mêmes et pas de se dire
on nous envahit en fait là c'est un
titre racoleur parce que de toute façon
tous les titres des journaux sont en
colère après à nous de savoir aussi
interpréter à notre manière sans être
raciste sans se dire qu'on nous envahit
je voudrais Daniel d'abord tu peux
parler en même temps non mais parce que
quand on regarde bien la vérité des
choses c'est que justement c'est pas
c'est pas des
Français enfin des Chinois non
j'arriverai pas à te demander des
Français originaires de Chine mais il y
a aussi des Cambodgiens des Thaïlande
des gens de Thaïlande des Vietnamiens
donc ce des Chinois moi déjà pourtant je
suis plutôt tendance à avoir j'aime pas
qu'on voit du racisme partout mais là je
le trouve vraiment honteux et le la
phrase parce qu'ils n'ont pas peur de
faire des heures c'est à dire que les
chinois sont courageux les Juifs sont
radins on en est là avec ce titre
excusez-moi moi ça m'a choqué pourtant
je suis rarement voilà je suis plutôt du
genre à dire qu'on voit du racisme
partout là je n'ai pas aimé ça du tout
allez regardez alors non 70% oui 27%